troisième volet de notre page d'été
consacrée à l'art de vivre à la
française
nous avons choisi un esthète capable de
passer avec la même facilité d'une
peinture de faïence à la sculpture sur
bois flottés reportage philippe roy
laurent blanc les murs de sa maison sont
tapissés de plats pas et finement
ciselés des témoins de 46 années
d'activité monsieur parce qu est ce qu
là une histoire particulière puisque
c'était l'exécution pour le concours du
meilleur ouvrier de france
pouvez vous revenir sur cet épisode
le diamètre est imposé les oxydes sont
déposés sur la sur l'émail crus et cuits
cuits à 960 degrés mais par contre tous
les autres devaient être pris comme une
une peinture à porcelaine c'est-à-dire
repris en deuxième cuisson à 8 150
degrés hélas ce plat là étaient faits
entièrement à neuf cent soixante degrés
directement sans passer en deux étapes
donc c'était encore même plus difficile
de d'exécution 80's daïni oui oui mais
c'est c'est des pièces qu'on fait une
fois dans sa vie quoi enfin après on les
garde en valeur sentimentale
exhumé du passé un album et des
souvenirs qui ont traversé le temps
chaque photo raconte une histoire un
moment particulier là soupire elle même
n'avait plus de couverts donc j'ai fait
refaire un couvercle entièrement en
terre enfin qu une première fois
ensuite remarié et redécorée aux
couleurs de de sa soupe hier qu'elle
était en difficultés à retrouver les
couleurs arrivé à rajuster le couvert au
diabète
parce que comme ya les retraits il faut
calculer les pourcentages de retrait et
que le couvercle s'emboîtent bien tout
le tout est en fait en colombie le
couvercle était en colombie donc dû
difficulté torsades pour la terre et
puis l'exécution
après ce reportage nous allons retrouver
notre invité dans son atelier
dites-nous encore monsieur passiez que
signifie tous ces objets tous ces
morceaux de bois disons tous ces
morceaux de bois sont des petits cadeaux
de la nature récupérés sur des plages
ses morceaux de bois vont être analysés
et disons que le tout ces deux de
décrypter ce qu'on peut en retirer
selon la forme d'une feinte de la façon
dont on le regarde
qu'est ce qui retient votre caisse qui
retient votre regard
un premier abord le premier abord c'est
la qualité du bois ça c'est
indispensable il faut un bois dur en
fait chaque morceau de bois commence à
vous parler
oui mais certains plus que d'autres
on peut ici entrevoir une tête une tête
et la une que j'ai déjà des as morceau
d'aile qui peut être fait la ou alors ou
alors on peut aussi voir un animal
voilà là c'est pareil j'ai ça ça ne fait
qu'une tête mais c'est une belle tête
alors après je vais trouver peut-être un
autre gros morceau de bois qui va
pouvoir compléter cette tête
donc c'est
disons de la pièce détachée nous allons
quitter votre atelier pour aller dans
votre salle d'exposition ce petit tête
dans le sable je me suis dit mais on
dirait bien une tête d'oiseau et
finalement je les travaille et un petit
peu parce que la nature avait déjà bien
fait les choses et j'ai découvert que
effectivement regardant on pouvait
découvrir des choses que la nature nous
offre à partir de ces toison vous allez
commencer à travailler sur d'autres
morceaux de bois et réalisé par exemple
c'est patineuse
absolument c'est disons que la nature
donne le mouvement et suivant le
mouvement qu'elle donne ou non on en
fait là pour moi elle représentait une
patineuse donc je les myopathies nous
faisons j'ai pas rechercher une des
parents en faire une patineuse bien
disons que le mouvement était déjà en
partie donné certaines pièces parlent
d'elles-mêmes pour le voit tout de suite
mes hôtes
on se surprend et même au fur et à
mesure qu'on commence à les travailler
on change on s'aperçoit qu'on peut faire
autre chose qu'on avait prévu que ce qui
avait été prévu au départ
notre prochain rendez-vous dans des
soieries d'ameublement un chef-d'oeuvre
ou presque